in occupied areas of Ukraine we have
documented summary executions and
attacks on individual civilians by
Russian armed forces and the and the
pervasive use of arbitrary detention and
enforced disappearances
since the 24th of February last year we
have documented 621 cases of enforced
disappearances and arbitrary Detention
of civilians by Russian Armed Forces
among the 127 that we interviewed after
their release 90 percent reported that
members of the Russian Security Forces
tortured and ill-treated them while in
detention
in some cases including with sexual
violence
five of these civilians were boys
between the ages of 14 and 17 years old
who had been forcibly disappeared by
Russian armed forces and subjected to
ill treatment and torture
since the 24th of February 2022 we have
documented 91 cases of enforced
disappearances and arbitrary detention
committed by Ukrainian Security Forces
of the 73 victims we interviewed 53
percent had been tortured or ill-treated
by members of Ukrainian armed forces and
law enforcement agencies
the prohibitions of torture and
arbitrary deprivation of Life are
absolute
all perpetrators must be held to account
and victims and their relatives must
enjoy the rights to remedy and Truth
in this regard we welcome the recent
adoption by the parliament of Ukraine of
a law amending the criminal code to
align National legislation with the U.N
convention Against torture
the horrendous human cost of war is also
evident in the cases of conflict-related
sexual violence which we have documented
since the 24th of February last year
by the 31st of January this year we had
recorded 133 victims comprising of 85
men 45 women and three girls
109 cases are attributable to the
Russian Armed Forces Russian law
enforcement authorities and Penitentiary
staff and 24 cases are attributable to
the security service of Ukraine the
Ukrainian police and Ukrainian civilians
or members of territorial Defense Forces
sexual violence frequently occurred when
civilians or prisoners of War were
detained as well as in residential areas
that were controlled by Russian Armed
Forces
we also documented transfers of
civilians to areas in occupied territory
or to the Russian Federation some of
which may amount to force transfers or
deportations
these transfers include children and
adults who lived in Social care
institutions and unaccompanied children
from parts of danetsk harkov Herson Kiev
and Odessa regions
while they were occupied by the Russian
Federation or temporary temporarily
controlled by Russian Armed Forces
I will now turn to our report on the
treatment of prisoners of War during all
stages of captivity from initial capture
to Transit and then places of internment
our team interviewed more than 400
prisoners of War approximately 200 on
each side
Ukraine provided us with unimpeded
confidential access to official places
of internment of Russian prisoners of
War
the Russian Federation did not give us
access
however we were able to carry out
confidential interviews with Ukrainian
prisoners of War upon their release
I will start with Russian prisoners of
war in the hands of Ukraine
we are deeply concerned about the
summary execution of up to 25 Russian
prisoners of war and persons ought to
combat by Ukrainian Armed Forces which
we have documented
this was often perpetrated immediately
upon capture on the battlefield while we
are aware of ongoing investigations by
Ukrainian authorities into five cases
involving 22 victims we are not aware of
any prosecution of the perpetrators
almost half of the 222 Russian prisoners
of War who we interviewed spoke of being
tortured or ill-treated by members of
Ukrainian armed forces and the sbu and
to a lesser extent Penitentiary staff
the majority of these cases occurred
during the initial stages of
apprehension and interrogation
prisoners of War were beaten
shot in the legs stabbed in the limbs
electrocuted subjected to mock
executions threats of sexual violence or
death
in permanent places of internment such
as pre-trial detention facilities or the
prisoner of war camp reports of mistreat
reports of mistreatment were
significantly less
we still received however complaints of
beatings in some of these facilities in
dinipro Venezia and harkev last spring
under international law prisoners of War
should not be held in closed confinement
while many remain in close confinement
in Ukraine we welcome progress through
the establishment of a prisoner of war
camp in leviv in the live region in
April 2022 we expect that the
authorities are addressing complaints of
humiliating and degrading treatment
which we received during our visit to
the camp in 20 in December 2022 no Camp
has been established in the Russian
Federation and prws are regularly held
in close confinement there
in relation to the treatment of
Ukrainian prisoners of War we are also
deeply concerned by the summary
execution of 15 Ukrainian prisoners of
War shortly after being captured by
Russian Armed Forces
the Wagner Wagner group military and
security contractors perpetrated 11 of
these executions
of the 203 Ukrainian prisoners of war
that we interviewed 67 percent fell into
the hands of the Russian forces after
their surrender was negotiated by
commanders in these cases we saw better
protection for them at the beginning of
their captivity
however the majority of Ukrainian
prisoners of War who were captured
during battle were tortured or treated
before internment
members of Russian armed forces and the
Russian Security Service tortured and
ill-treated them to extract military
information to intimidate or humiliate
them or as a form of Retribution
forms of torture included beating
electrocution or in several cases being
shot or stabbed in the legs
mock executions were also common the
report describes one case where a
prisoner of war died from injuries
within hours after he was tortured
conditions for many Ukrainian prisoners
of War were shocking
a prisoner of war we spoke to told us
and I quote we were provided with just
enough food to Keep Us Alive
access to Medical Care was often
insufficient or unavailable sometimes
leading to dire consequences the report
documents that five of them died in
internment reportedly due to the lack of
medical attention
the number of documented cases of
torture and ill treatment during
internment in Penitentiary facilities is
shocking more than 84 percent endured
such mistreatment
Penitentiary staff subjected prisoners
of War to so-called welcome beatings
upon their arrival beat and electrocuted
them regularly during inspections in
cells and while walking them around the
facilities
members of the Russian Federal
Penitentiary services and those in
charge of many places of internment in
russian-occupied territory
systematically engaged in such practices
against prisoners of War
former prisoners of War told us told our
colleagues that they dreaded weekly
trips to the shower which inevitably
ended in beatings and humiliation often
with sexual overtones
we documented that five prisoners of War
died from injuries sustained during
torture and internment
cruelty and large-scale impact on
civilians that we have seen over the
last year will continue unless both
parties to the conflict ensure full
compliance with International
humanitarian law
and when violations do occur prompt
action must be taken first within the
ranks of the army itself and also
through full and effective
investigations and prosecutions of those
responsible for the acts committed and
those in command
the cases of summary executions torture
and ill treatment arbitrary detention
and sexual violence must not be allowed
to continue
it is now over a year since the Russian
Federation launched its armed attack
against Ukraine which has led to the
violations that I have outlined today
in the words of our High Commissioner we
appeal again for respect for the
sanctity of life for human dignity for
respect for the principle of humanity
thank you
foreign